Yeah.
My name is heath row and I'm research
operations manager for the brand studio of
Google.
And we're here today with Jason Calacanis.
Jason is a technology entrepreneur,
angel investor and the host of a weekly
podcast called this week in startups.
He's the founder of a series
of conferences that bring
entrepreneurs together
with potential investors.
And he was a scout for top tier
silicon valley venture capital firms,
sequoia capital. He lives in
San Francisco, California.
Used to live down this way in southern
California and is author of a relatively
new book.
It's about a month old called angel,
how to invest in technology startups,
timeless advice from an angel investor
who turned $100,000 into $100 million
published in July by Harper business.
I've known Jason for probably 20 years
now. Haven't seen him for ever and a day.
So it's good to have you here,
Jason. Thanks for having me. Heath.
And we were journalists together
back in the day that we were covering
technology. Well, let's start
theirs cause I first met you.
It wasn't photocopied when I met you,
but silicon alley reporter you went on
to digital coast reporter web blogs,
Netscape,
Mahalo.
That journalism is all generally
focusing on the gathering,
curation and promotion of ideas
and powerful ideas. Yeah, I was,
I'm lucky enough to be in New York
when the Internet hit in 1994,
95 CD roms were becoming
a big deal and multimedia.
And then all of a sudden the Internet
became commercialized with the Netscape
browser supporting images.
And I started a Zeen Chris back then too,
if you want it to be
important in the world,
the real startup idea you had was the xen
and xen just meant a magazine that was
not professionally produced,
but that was literally a photocopied.
And so after starting that photocopy
xen silicon alley reporter,
it quickly grew into a print magazine
and have 300 pages and I got caught up in
the whole.com sort of wave of innovation.
And so I got very lucky.
But being a journalist is a great way to
learn how to interview founders and to
cut through bs. And, um, you're
kind of a detective, right?
Like when you're a journalist,
you have to ask questions,
let the person talk and maybe try
to figure out what the truth is.
And when you're an angel investor,
it's very similar. You're,
you're talking to founders and
sometimes they're tourists.
They're people who are just trying on
the concept of being a founder. They,
they saw the social network or they,
they seen how Uber or Google or
Airbnb have grown and they say,
I want to be a jerk,
I'm going to be a founder.
And then they start pitching
investors and you realize, wow,
this person's going to give up.
This idea does not have real meaning to
them and they have no idea how hard it
is to be a founder.
So I think that journalism background
has helped a number of people,
including Michael Moritz, who was
the original investor in Google, um,
was a journalist and wrote a book
actually about Apple, uh, back in the 80s.
And so it's,
uh,
it's one of the great paths I think to
investing is either being a founder today
you can be a founder and then go on to
be an investor or somebody in growth.
That's another big one.
Right now everybody's looking for
growth hackers to become investors. Um,
and then journalists,
it used to be Mbas,
so you have to go get a Harvard Mba or
Stanford Mba and then you know, you,
your fraternity brothers would get
you into a venture firm. Now it's,
it's really delightful that the whole
model has flipped and it's like if you
don't have operational experience,
they really don't want you
to venture capital end.
It used to be all venture capitalists
had zero operating experience and they
were all finance,
you know,
NBA Bros and all the firms were
just groups of, you know, Harvard,
Stanford Mbas.
Now it's totally changed.
They don't want to hire people without
operational experience cause the founders
can see through it immediately.
They're like,
you've never run a company and
I'm going to take your advice.
I'm going to take a pass on that.
And what do you think caused that or what,
what happened in the industry that,
that led to that shift and thinking?
I'm the founder friendly
movement. I think, um,
when a market gets hot and uh,
really Sean part,
I would give Sean Parker a lot of credit
for it. You know, Sean Parker and Google,
uh,
and Michael Borowitz had a little bit of
a back and forth over Plaxo back in the
day.
And he then brought Zuckerberg out
to silicon valley and famously,
you know,
left sequoia at the altar and wouldn't
let them invest because of how he felt he
had been treated. And then founders
fund, Peter Teal created and,
and Sean Parker created founders fund.
And the reason they named it founders
fund was specifically to attack sequoia
and other venture firms and say,
those firms are interested
in kicking out the founders.
These firms are interested in,
you know, being founder friendly.
And then that just changed everybody's
thinking like we have to be founder
friendly, you know, uh, and you know,
there's pros and cons to it. Yeah.
How do you balance that,
the operational experience with a
maybe an idea driven founder? Yeah.
Um, it's pretty interesting when you
look at the history of Silicon Valley.
If you were to say I'm only going
to invest in founders who have great
experience, you would miss Larry
and Sergei, you would've missed, um,
Bill Gates and you would have missed
Zuckerberg. You wouldn't have missed,
you know, Uber or some other
companies that had serial founders.
Twitter had a serial founder obviously
and Evan Williams. Um, so a lot,
there is actually a theory that the,
the biggest outcomes are by
people who are first timers.
It's not actually backed up by
reality. It's kind of 50, 50. Um,
but the thing about venture
capital and angel investing,
and she don't have to hit everything.
So if you miss Google and you get
Facebook or you get Facebook and you don't
invest in Google or we get
airbnb and you don't get Uber,
well you have to do is hit one.
And then they let you write a book.
I hit six UNICORNS, you know, in
the first hundred investments.
Now when I wrote the book
and did the book deal,
I had three UNICORNS and
since the book came out,
three of the other companies have
tipped over into that territory.
So it's a pretty good track record.
But you know I,
the reason I wrote the book
really is it's so opaque,
the idea of being an angel investor
in doing it professionally,
but because of large the size,
the scale of Internet companies now and
the amount of wealth being created has
gotten so great that now we went
from just maybe 10 or 15 years ago,
10 years ago when I started
angel investing, I started
about seven years ago,
but about 10 years ago when I
was a founder raising money,
there was only like a dozen or two dozen
angel investors of note and you could
kind of make the rounds very quickly.
Now I'd say in Silicon Valley there are
500 to a thousand people who do it as a
primary activity.
In other words,
he spent 50% of their time
on angel investing or more.
So I think there's going to be a
professional angel investing class.
The vcs have retreated and said,
we don't want to take risk anymore.
We don't want to do a
series a that's speculative.
Bring US companies because
there's so many companies,
they've moved down treme and they just
bring us companies that have revenue and
traction.
If it's an enterprise company
with $100,000 or $50,000 a month,
we'll meet with them.
If it's a consumer product and it's got
10 to 50,000 people using it in a day
and you've got three to six
months of traffic, we'll meet,
we'll probably wait till you hit 10
million users a month before we invest and
do a series a.
But really that's opened up this huge
swath of what I call the Goldilocks Zone,
pre series a pre a venture
capitalist wanting to join the board,
but post the product being launched in
the market because let's all face it,
we know that you can get any product
to market or I'd say nine out of 10
products,
you can get some version of it to market
for either sweat equity or a $100,000
or less. Right? So if you wanted to
build slack or Twitter or even Uber,
you could do that for low hundreds of
thousands of dollars. In other words,
people can bootstrap it,
friends and family,
some close friends to get that Beta out.
And that goldilocks zone is where I think
a lot of wealth creation is going to
occur in the future because you've
removed the 99% of founders who never get
their product to market from
your investment criteria.
And then you don't have the vcs in with
their sharp elbows blocking the angel
investors yet.
And that's just probably a,
I'll call it a three year window in most
startups where angels can participate,
there's probably about four or five
rounds of funding in there as well. Uh,
anybody here,
um,
have a friend who's actively running a
startup and is raised money in the last
12 months or so, right? So almost
half the room and if you talk to them,
they probably will raise five
rounds of funding before a series a,
it used to be raised in angel round
friends and family and angel or seed round
and then a series a. Now you
raise friends, friends and family.
Then you do a pre seed round,
a seed round, an angel round,
a pre series a,
a series a extension.
I mean they come up with all
these crazy names for them,
but just call them $250,000 to
one point $5 million rounds.
And usually there's six convertible
notes converting when they finally get to
series a,
which means you can really take her time
as an angel investor and get to know
the company.
There is really no
need to panic and like I
have to get in this round,
you can actually wait and just build a
relationship with the founders over six
months,
which is kind of what I outlined in the
book is my theory on how to do it given
today's environment,
uh,
which is there's a lot of startups and
they raise a lot of rounds of funding and
you really don't want to be investing
in startups before they finish their
product because it's a bit of a towel.
If you can't finish the product
without raising a ton of money,
maybe you're not an actual builder.
Sometimes it's true,
but most of the time you're not an actual
builder. Yeah. It's 99 all over again.
I mean it is highly
tourist season right now.
So the opportunity is still very great,
but a lot of people are trying on and
playing the role of founder and what
they'll find is it's a really,
really difficult job.
It's very hard to be the founder.
You don't sleep at night,
you've got somewhere between six
weeks and 12 months of runway.
Your product is probably under assault
from competitors and investors are
waiting to see and people are deciding
between joining Facebook or Google and
getting huge RSUs are coming
to your company and you've
got to convince them and
then they come for six months and leave.
So it's, it's very hard. And I think,
you know, that's, that's one of the, um,
the interesting parts of this is just
trying to figure out who's going to stick
with the idea.
Because most days as a founder I would
say are not super rewarding there.
They're generally hard.
The reward you get for being a founder
of a technology company is you hire the
smartest people you know,
and they all bring you the problems.
They can't solve that, you know? So like
literally every week it's like, hey,
we got all this stuff done, but here's
what we didn't get done. Can you help us?
Wow, that's challenging. You know,
that's, that's Elan's life is like, okay,
I hired the smartest people
in the room and now they're,
they can't figure out these
things and I got to, you know,
figure out how to get
the model three out on,
tie in and get the Falcon
to land properly. Right.
It's a hard life and it never gets easier.
So you mentioned sequoia.
Do you still work as a scout for,
so I'm still part of this
request scouts program.
I do like a investment
once a year with them,
but I just finished up my first proper
fund. I had a $10 million Angel Fund,
which was basically my friends,
uh, and my money. And then, um,
I'll do something in the future.
Uh,
you can't talk about those types
of things, right? Obviously. Um,
but one would suspect I'm going to stay
in the game and do another hundred 50
investments. Uh, and then
I'll me at 300 investments.
It's very hard to scale angel investing.
That's one of the things
I'm trying to do right now.
And part of the reason I wrote the book
was I think there's a lot of people who
have money in very boring asset
classes. I call a dead money. You know,
you've got your money in
bonds, real estate, you know,
some equally balanced equities
portfolio using Wealthfront,
which is a great tool for doing that.
I'm an investor in their company
and so you have these, uh, you know,
swaths of money that are sitting there
and it's not kind of helping society in
any way or changing things.
I think people should take maybe 5% of
that net worth 10% of that net worth and
put it in something that's highly risky.
It may not return,
it may not have the stability of,
you know,
the stock market balanced portfolio that
people talk about that returns four to
7% a year in doubles every eight years.
But you have that outside chance of going
in a hundred to one on an investment
or a thousand to one which would
then double your net worth.
So I think people are overly risk averse
and I tried to outline in the book,
here's a strategy,
maybe investing in syndicates,
people know Angel List or seed
invest or I have my own syndicate.
Now Jason's syndicate,
people know that they can invest
alongside of angel investors.
That's a great way to
learn how to do this.
You're investing $1,000 or $3,000 in
each startup and you do 20 startups.
All of a sudden he's may
have invested $60,000 total,
but you've done 30 investments and you
are watching the monthly updates of 30
companies.
It's a great way to build a network and
get in the game for what most people
would consider the price of one
angel investment of 50 or $60,000.
So I try to outline all of that in the
book of how to slowly learn how to do
this. And I think it's probably the
most exciting career you could have.
You get to hang out with the smartest
people who want to change the world and
meet them when they have, you know, one
to 10 employees in their company. Right.
It's pretty exciting,
I have to say.
And even if you lost
half your money doing it,
you'd be losing half of say five or 10%
of your net worth the network and the
knowledge you would build during that
time would easily make up for that two and
a half percent of your net worth.
Right, right. Regardless. And you're,
one of the things I liked most about
the book was the kind of attitude of
democratizing angel investment.
You mentioned earlier today that you
know there's a couple of hundred angel
investors in the valley,
but this is saying that grandma
can be an angel investor,
college student can be an angel investor.
Talk us through some of the steps or
the advice that you would give people.
So I think it's purposely opaque.
We,
we have a very unfair system in the
United States where there's two classes of
people,
accredited investors and nonaccredited
people who make over $200,000 a year for
a couple of years in a row
are considered accredited.
If they have a million
or $2 million in cash,
you can look it up on the SCCs website.
And then the other 95% of America
are considered nonaccredited.
But those 95% can go to Vegas and bet on
a sports team or they can play in their
local poker game or they can buy,
you know,
they can do whatever they want with
their money. Um, using bad judgment,
good judgment,
et cetera.
They could even buy stocks in the public
market without having to check with
anybody. But the idea of
investing in private companies,
which is where ultra wealth is created
really outsized outcomes, is very,
there's nowhere you can have these kinds
of odds to get these kinds of returns
except in Silicon Valley and startups.
So I think that we'll see that change.
It's in Europe,
which is interesting because it's a
pretty protectionist kind of a vibe over
there. Obviously they allow everybody
to invest their money however they want.
So here in the United States we have a
little bit of a history of, you know,
not trusting people with their own money,
but that's unraveling.
It's good intention.
But now they have something called
equity crowdfunding where sites like seed
Invest in republic are taking companies
and allowing them to raise money from
civilians, nonaccredited investors
for $500. So I look at it and say,
you know what? I see people
out there spending money on
all kinds of dopey stuff.
I think making investments in
startups would be a lot better.
And if you were to ask all of the
Etsy sellers early Etsy sellers,
hey, you're, you're not
accredited, but we have, you know,
5,000 creators on the platform,
you can each invest up to a
thousand dollars in the platform.
How many of them would have done it?
And what kind of wealth would be created?
Ebay, same story. Think about all the
adsense partners in the early days.
If you had told me when we were in
in gadget, is adsense going to work?
I was like, well, we're making
$3,000 a day off of it. You know,
10 years ago I would have
made that baton but pre uh,
public Google shares for sure, but that
opportunity wasn't open TV than me.
I wasn't accredited yet.
At that time I was negative 10
grand actually and my bank account.
So I was stuck. So I'm hoping that
all changes over time. And since we,
since I wrote the book,
it's been 25 days,
we had 1200 people in our Angel
Syndicate and we've had 700 more join.
So we're averaging something like 30
people a day applying and then accepting
maybe half of them. And so I think
this is going to change in a big way.
A company Cafe X, which I'm an investor
in, which is a robotic coffee machine, um,
who has raised to um,
not equity crowdfunding but to
syndicates of node, like, you know,
upwards of $1 million from investors,
10 K at a time.
Now we have hundreds of investors on
that cap table under one umbrella.
My syndicate and all of those people get
to participate. I'm super proud of that.
If I becomes a Unicorn and those people
turn 10,000 and he goes a hundred x,
I mean I would be super excited to see
people become millionaires or to generate
that kind of wealth. And I've seen
it happen. I mean, in Silicon Valley,
I see people who are pretty dopey,
make angel investments and make
millions of dollars pretty regularly,
and it should be open to more people.
And most people have a good eye for this.
If you were to ask anybody who was on
Linkedin in the first two years who were
recruiters or HR executives,
those HR executives and recruiters who
would normally not have access had the
insight information.
They knew that linkedin was going to
become a very significant platform.
The early creators on Youtube knew that
it was going to be something special.
It was obvious to them,
but they could not participate into it.
And Chad would have absolutely allowed
youtube creators to invest if that was
allowed. And that's what we're
slowly starting to have happen.
It started last June and it's been a year.
The companies that are doing equity
crowdfunding, I would say, um,
are the Wa in some cases the ones
that didn't clear market with venture
capitalists and angels.
But I think that's slowly
starting to change where people,
the scariness of doing something new
like angel is syndicates was very new and
people were very scared of it.
That's flipped over.
So if everybody were to invest 5%
of their net worth and startups,
I think the world will
get better a lot quicker.
We create a lot more jobs and we say
a lot more problems getting solved.
So I actually believe that this is
something bigger than just making money.
I think it's making change in the world.
If you think about all the
great change that's occurred,
it's because some angel
investors supported some
crazy kids who had some crazy
idea, whether it was Larry
and Sergei or chat and uh,
the team at Youtube or
snapchat and you know, they,
they all needed some small
amount of money to get going.
And these experiments are worth trying
and if you lose, you know, six, seven,
eight or nine out of 10 bats in the
last bad returns, more than 10 x,
you're in the black.
Uh,
and just as a gambler myself
as a semi professional gambler,
in fact like high stakes gambler in poker,
like it's,
it's very hard for people to deal with
losing six or seven hands in a row.
Anybody here play poker?
Anybody here ever loose seven or eight
hands in a row when they were the odds?
Favor? Yeah. People are
raising their hand. I mean,
it's going to happen one out of
every 500 games you play, right?
Like when you're not ready for it,
you stare at the ceiling and go,
how did I lose all of those heads?
I lost six hands in a row that I should
have won. It's a very odd feeling. Uh,
that's actually how the normal for angel
investing if you're doing it right.
Like when I introduced people
to Uber 17 of 22 or 23,
oh,
only three people said yes.
Out of maybe 20 or 25 people I introduced
them to and we're talking about the
greatest investors in the world said no
to Uber and they said no two or three
times. Um, and I'm the
three people who said yes,
all have nine figure positions.
Uh, and the people who said no,
or some of them have 10 figure position,
some of the people said no.
Just every time they see me,
the way I should have listened.
And the list of reasons of why a
startup will fail is very long.
And the list of reasons of wildly
succeeded, they're very short.
And so what I've learned to do is
work against my natural, you know,
our biological nature is to be
conservative as humans, right?
If you were to swim across the river,
the river might take you or
the alligator might take you.
Or if you go over the hill,
the line might eat you.
We are conservative
animals for good reason,
but we don't need to be conservative
in this aspect of her life.
We should be risk taking,
but risk taking is something that
people just don't have in their DNA.
Did you have to unlearn what
your DNA is telling you.
You should be taking this risk. There
is no crocodile that's going to eat you.
If you lose your 10 k here's gonna
lose 10 K and make it back next month.
So don't worry about it.
It's fine to burn that 10
K it's a worthwhile risk
and people overestimate the
downsides so much. It's crazy. Let's,
let's unpack that a bit. So when,
when you're looking at an opportunity,
what characteristics or
qualities do you look for?
And the question behind the question,
what makes you push past
that? Sure. Fear. Yeah.
Um,
so I usually do make that long list of
reasons just to get it out of my system
and then I just take it on our,
cross it out or rip it up.
Cause I assume that a smart founder,
we'll get through those and you have to
ask yourself not what could go wrong,
but what could go right,
what could go right for the company
and if those things are even a one in a
hundred chance or a one in
50 chance of it going right.
If the odds pay off higher than that,
it's worth doing.
And so that's Kinda how I look at the
entire world right now. And I've had to,
I've changed my whole thinking. I
tend to bet on people. Um, and I,
I'm good at reading people and I think
the biggest mistakes I've made in
investing, which were
Tesla, Twitter and Zynga,
I wasn't an angel investor at the time,
but my friends were starting
those companies and I
could have invested in each
of them and that would have been a $50
million return on average each based on
the check size.
I was writing shortly after that.
And in every case with Twitter was,
I just thought Twitter was such
a terrible idea because if it's,
I sat there with Evan and Biz and I said
to them like, they were like, hey look,
just take her blackberry out and we'll
text four oh four oh four and you say
what you're having for breakfast and
business is going to say what he's having
for breakfast and fcs,
what they're having for business.
And all of our phones go off in the s
it was an SMS service at the beginning.
Yeah, there were no apps
and I was like, Oh my God,
Evan is Evan Williams. I
was like, this is so stupid.
Nobody cares what business having for
breakfast or what we're having for
breakfast and you just
cost me like 4 cents.
I'm going to run through my whole SMS
plan and there's no blog post here.
You create a blogger. He
sold it to Google, right?
Like people wrote their thoughts.
It was full thoughts and now you're saying
just it's the same as blogger except
without the blog post. It's just the
title and now he's back to medium. Right.
Well, and that was like, you
realize that if this succeeds,
it's going to be a cacophony of idiots.
Like literally everybody who
can't put together a blog post,
which is only 400 words,
they're going to write 140 characters
instead of 140 or 300 words.
Every idiot in the world is going to
be on this thing all day saying stupid
things and it's going to
be getting magnified like
grace. I was absolutely right
and it costs me $50 million. So
then I realized, you know what?
I don't have to know this is if there,
if there is Jason's law
of Angel Investing, it's,
I don't need to know if your
idea is going to succeed.
I just need to know if
you're going to succeed.
So since I started that
approach to angel investing,
which is does this person have passion?
Do they have skill?
Do they understand how to
build a product and a team?
I look for those traits and when you
ask people questions, short questions,
what are you working on?
Why will this idea work?
Now has something changed in the
world that makes this idea work now?
Or tell me about the product
design or why are you doing this?
Just like literally pointing out one
feature of the product. Say, wow,
what is this syndication thing,
this little snippet here on Youtube.
Why is that important? Like,
if you were to ask, you know,
Chad earlier that it was like,
oh,
because people want to put videos on
their site, there's no easy way to do it.
They have to put up a server.
So if they would,
if they put this javascript
into their blogger.com account,
they can put a video on their site.
Oh, why is that important? Well,
because it's free marketing for us.
We're giving them free hosting a videos.
They give us free marketing to their
audience and we're going to grow the
service that way. That was the why
now, syndication and cloud computing.
So I'm now, I now have
three or four founders, um,
who ha are creating products,
um,
that I invested in after
investing in their last company.
So Raul created a company called
reportive that people may have used.
That was that little sidebar in Gmail
that told you everybody's social stats and
this is their Twitter handle and
here's a bunch of information on them.
He sold that to linkedin. Now he's
doing something called superhuman,
which is like a better Gmail. I
mean like, well anyway, I mean,
I don't make anybody feel,
feel bad in the room.
It's kind of like nobody's
taken on Jean Allen a long time,
rather it feels like gmls like it was so
radical when it came out 15 years ago.
So he's kind of taking an approach of uh,
uh,
the same approach that GML took towards
the, of like a radical email client.
And so when he sold reportive, I made two
or three times my money and I told him,
hey, this is fine. Like I, I'd rather
we don't sell, but okay, uh, you're,
you got four cofounders. I only ask one
thing role, when you have your next idea,
you call me and I can be the
first investor. He called
me, I put $1 million in,
I joined the board, boom,
we're off to the races.
And this has happened like three times
now where somebody who I invested in who
got a single or double or lost my
money, we come back, we do it again.
So I'm investing in the arc of a founder's
career and I think that's the way
that's in my mind, the best way to do it
as if you know somebody who's a winner.
If you know they work hard,
you know they're passionate,
you know they're not going to give up.
These are the qualities of the
founders who when they won't give up,
they have skills and they
have passion for the space.
If an intelligent person wakes up one
day and realize is how hard it's going to
be and how much sacrifice there is and
they're not passionate about with the
idea, the rational thing
to do is to quit and say,
this is going to be too hard.
You have to really,
really care to blow up two or three
rockets and still go to work the next day.
You know,
Ilan was,
he's a close personal friend of mine
and like when he blew up the second or
third rocket, I mean it was,
you know, I think that was,
that pushed him to the brink. I
mean he was really, really focused,
but he wasn't going to
give up and he was it.
It strengthened his resolve if anything.
And now you watch these idiots
on Twitter, Baxter, Twitter,
cacophony of idiots like criticizing the
model three for it being Mike a couple
of weeks late or something.
And Kenny hit the numbers.
I mean like I was just driving the
car for a couple of days last week.
It's got 300 mile range.
It's drives like a Porsche.
Like these idiots are still doubting him.
It's like,
did you not,
have you not been paying attention like
these guys that it's like literally the,
there were always these haters out there
and doubters who throw rocks at these
companies who are trying
to change the world.
And literally if Elon
succeeds like no more smog,
you know, energy independence
from dictators who own
big swats of fossil fuels,
global warming,
like a free transportation,
eventually no more road deaths
because of self driving.
Like there's this whole swath of
incredible things that will happen.
So it's so amazing to me how people could
not be positive about what's happening
in the world. We're trending,
everything is trending so much in,
in the right direction and there are small
issues here on the sides that we have
to solve. Some of them are big, but
I look at them all as incredibly, um,
solvable. Incredibly. It's
solvable, including jobs, including,
you know, environmental issues.
I think we can solve all of them,
which is a lack of,
um,
positivity and a lack of paying
attention to what's happened to date.
We seem to solve a lot of the problems
that we face as humanity. If we are,
you know, India fatiguable and clever
in our approach and we're clever.
We're clever species.
Well,
let's talk about the people building
that better world because the book is
written kind of in the guise
of how to become an investor,
but it would also be really useful to
people who want to build a company that
others would invest. It is really about
talk about that. Yeah. Well, as a founder,
you know, everybody's trying to figure
out how to hack investors. Like, I mean,
the whole point of y Combinator for the
last couple of years has been how to
manipulate and get an edge
on the investors. And I think
it's the wrong approach.
Um, I think they've realized it's the
wrong approach because you're really in it
together. You don't want to
try to trick the investors.
So people are constantly asking me,
how do you get an investor to invest?
You know? And it's like, well,
if you have a great team and
a great company and great
product and customers who
love you and some level of traction,
you're going to meet a hundred investors,
you know,
and eventually six or seven of them
will invest and then it's that simple.
But they're trying to figure out how
to hack the investment and instead of
trying to hack the investment,
how about hacking the usage and the
engagement level of your customers?
So if you had a hundred units of work,
this idea of spending 90 units on
hacking me, investing investor community,
which is a pretty sophisticated group
of people to try and hack. Like,
why not spend those 90 cycles trying to
triple the engagement of your current
customer base and then explain with
the last 10 units of energy here,
here's what we did to increase
engagement and tell that story.
So I think this is the rookie mistake a
is just too much gaming of the investor
community and trying to figure
out how to hack it and what,
what are they thinking?
It's pretty simple what they're thinking.
Does this person have the ability to
build a team that can build a product that
delights users and if they can get
that product to market, you've,
you've built that credibility.
So and to think it's going to happen
after one meeting is probably silly.
Like it usually happens over five,
six, seven meetings and email updates.
So I'm so a pro this monthly update
that I require it from my investments
because the first hundred
investments I did,
I didn't require them
to send monthly updates.
Now in my legal documents that require
a monthly update that starts with the
most important metrics,
how many months of runway to have,
how much cash is left in the bank.
When do we need to raise money next?
What's the revenue?
What's the user engagement?
And so I've been making
this a requirement, uh,
because so many founders don't send these
updates and then they don't have the
opportunity to raise money from the
investors who they've already convinced to
put money in because those
investors lose faith.
What I tell founders now is if
you want me to invest, you know,
so many deals coming at me right now.
Um,
put me on your monthly
update for three months.
I'll read your monthly updates
for three months before I invest.
And then I'll decide like looking at your
monthly update when it's right for me
to invest when it's in my goldilocks zone.
And so the best thing that founders
can do is really understand what that
investors invested in and what,
what their timing typically is.
There are investors who like to invest
when the company's worth $1 million or $2
million before it launches their product
because they're product driven people
and they make products.
So they want to be involved in the
product creation and they want to be there
for the day. It launches, there's other
people who want to be there, you know,
right after it launches like myself,
like I want to just see six weeks of data.
There are other people who want to see two
years of data, you know, vcs typically,
and you just have to know your audience.
Um,
and so I get monthly updates
more consistently in some
cases from companies I
passed on investing in than
the ones I did invest in.
Like literally I have somebody who was
sending me legal documents to sign for an
approval of a Silicon Valley Bank
loan and credit facility. You know,
when you're an investor you have to
sign off on these future investments.
And I'm like, I haven't heard
from you in like 18 months,
what's going on with the company? It's
like explaining everything that occurred.
I'm like,
you could've just done this monthly like,
or whatever and it would
catch up. Yes. It's weird. Um,
so I think the monthly update is,
puts people on this cadence where they
can build trust and build credibility
with investors.
And that's what you're really trying
to do with those investors is just just
trying to build this sense that you're
credible and you're not stomping.
Like when people get the sense that like
you're not going to give up and that
this train is leaving the station
and they can either get on it or not.
That makes it a very
attractive investments.
Like this person's not going to give up.
And that's a,
at least you know that your money didn't
get burned without people even trying.
Right.
Um,
it's nice to know that people try it and
I don't mind people losing the money.
I mean, as long as they tried
hard, that's really the goal. Okay.
Um, you've lived in New York,
you've got many, many years.
You've lived in southern
California, 30 and 10. Yeah. And uh,
now San Francisco for three. Yeah. How
do the business communities differ?
How does being an investor in
those communities differ? Sure. Um,
you can build a great company in
those three cities. No problem.
I'm a great founder. We'll build a
great business in those three cities.
If you're in southern California,
over here in New York,
you're going to have less
competition as a founder for talent.
Talent will stay longer, costs will be a
third less. Those are all great things.
You're going to have to come to the
valley to meet with investors and those
investors will not mind going to New York
or Los Angeles because they're awesome
cities.
And if you were to rank the three cities,
it's like New York's the
greatest city in the world.
Los Angeles is probably
the better lifestyle. Um,
and very similar to New York as people
who have lived in both cities will say
I'm in San Francisco is the worst run,
great city in America.
It's like just horribly run. It's
a completely dysfunctional, um,
and like can't even solve like
minor issues. So, um, it's pretty,
pretty tragic in a way.
But if you're a founder there,
obviously you have access
to more a wider talent pool.
I wouldn't say necessarily better. Uh,
but the costs are ridiculous now. I mean,
it's really like show
stopping lead bad. Um, so the,
the high art I think right now is to put
your headquarters in Silicon Valley in
a we work office and then have everybody
in Arizona or Los Angeles or San Diego
or have your team at Waterloo doing your
code and have a mail drop in the valley.
Basically it's like having this little
like headquarters and the valley until
you can get some, you know, a valley
vcs VC to put a series a and, um,
your chances as an angel investor in
hitting a Unicorn are greatly reduced
outside of Silicon Valley. Just
statistically, everybody knows that.
And if you look at the
hundred billion dollar out,
the 50 billion or $100 billion outcomes,
those are almost universally
come from silicon valley.
You do have Amazon and Microsoft
as the two notable exceptions,
and you have snapchat down here, but
snapchat might be a $5 billion company,
not a $10 billion plus company.
So what I say in the book is like,
do to be a great investor.
Do you need to be in Silicon Valley?
It's the answer's yes.
Now you could go there.
So I lived here and was
going up there weekly. Um,
and that was a lot of work. Um, but that,
that's how I did investing and I hit
a four of the six unicorns doing that.
So it just going up there and going
up for two days, three days a month,
you have a chance to just book all your
meetings and, and get it done that way.
So there's something very special
about the, the community up there,
but you see something very nice
happening down here as well.
And I think the question is,
will those people who make money off
of snapchat or working for dollar shave
club,
will they become angels are not,
and will they start investing
in this community or not?
And that's what happened
in New York. You know, the,
the silicon alley reporter days,
there weren't that many investors.
Things started to work out and you had
someone like Kevin Ryan from DoubleClick
who had made a ton of money,
launched business insider, um,
and uh, a DNS company
work. I'd CDN company,
can't remember the name of it.
That did very well.
And he also did a flashlights out, so he
was just investing in everything there.
Um, and, and you're starting to see
that cycle. I think actually lear hippo,
Erica Poe was at Ziff Davis in New York
and then they did lear hippo and they
started a venture firm that invested
in buzzfeed and Huffington post and all
that kind of stuff.
So you see that renewal happening,
new firms and new individuals
in those cities. So, uh,
Stockholm is another crazy example
of nine unicorns out of Stockholm.
That's crazy. How'd that happen? But
I've been asking for an explanation.
Nobody can give it to me except that they
worked really hard over there because
there's no sunlight long.
Lynchers lat long winters,
they just like worked for 12 hours a day.
But you know,
there were nine that came out of there,
which is pretty, pretty amazing. Um,
so innovation can come out of any place.
How are things going here after the memo?
I'm curious a lot of talk about that
or no, wait was like, I was like,
what should we talk about? They're
like Google memo, Uber and benchmark.
They like it was all the
controversial topics. Well, to a,
to side step that question entirely. Go
ahead. Let's talk a little bit about it,
about growth and optimism
growth and on what,
what areas do you see
a nascent opportunity?
And we've talked a little bit about free
energy. We've talked about robotics.
Yeah. Uh, well, you know,
in our industry we
always have false starts.
And so if you think about
Vr as an example, uh,
how many people will remember VRML
the virtual reality markup language?
Like there was like,
literally we,
we're going to go through the Jaco index
and be like flying through in three d
and like picking arts and leisure
or photography nudes, you know,
whenever I'm like pulling out the folders
and it was going to be this incredible
Gerald linear world and,
um, it never happened.
And now send you put an Oculus on and
you're like, wow, that's incredible.
But still hasn't happened, right? Like
when is that going to happen? Exactly. Um,
VR VR might be a false start right now.
The headsets seem extremely expensive
and it might still be four or five years
away. Before we have 100
million people using it, right?
And you really need to have
tens of millions of people
to possess the technology
in order to have 10
million use it in a day.
And that's when you sort of hit this
tipping point. Now ar feels a lot closer,
right?
So that,
that's something where it feels like
you could have 10 million people a day
using it, you know, two years from now.
And so I do think there's something there
with ar and Vr, whether it's two, three,
four years. So that would make it
a good time to start investing.
But people who invested two
years ago and VR companies,
those companies are running
out of money right now.
And they're desperate because they
thought they would be selling $5 million
worth of software apps and they're
selling 50,000 a year. And it's, you know,
like really early adopters.
Ai was when we had a lot of false starts
on and now it's not a false start.
So I've been pitched on six or seven
companies that are taking AI into Schuman,
resources, customer support, legal, um,
and it's pretty obvious
that like, I dunno, 60, 70,
80% of legal docs that have been created,
you should just be able to be like,
okay Google, I need a nondisclosure with
Jason that says this, this and this.
And then it's just like, okay, we sent
it over to him and then I get an okay,
I sign it and boom, like we, we
could do most contracts that way.
Uh,
and so white collar jobs like that I
think are going to be at risk in the next
10, 20 years because it's going to be
so easy to do things like contracts, uh,
or accounting, you know, these kinds
of things are ais for real obviously.
And you guys all know that from deep
mind and the impact that's going to have,
and that's a horizontal impact.
So when you have something like AI and
machine learning hitting at this pace and
people learning about it this quickly
and implementing it, tensorflow,
all this other stuff, like it's
getting easier to implement Watson,
etc. So that means you're going to have
a whole group of entrepreneurs being
backed by angels to try to,
you know,
we do every vertical to make an AI.
And if you enabled,
if you look at Google photos, I
think it's a great example. You know,
Google photos is just
anticipating what I want.
And I don't know if anybody works on
Google photos here, but high five. Um,
do you guys uh, crushing it? I mean like,
I'm like a download Google photos from
my phone. Like for a year people like,
you have to get Google photos on your
iPhone. I'm like, no, I don't. I already,
I got Icloud, I'm paying for it. And
then I get Google photos. I'm like, oh,
that's pretty dope. Like, you know,
it's telling me like I should check out
these photos and it's like telling me
like, look here, we made a video for
you because we know you like videos.
It's kind of scary.
Like it's figuring out what I like and
I'm delighting me every day and it's
obviously juicing machine learning
and AI to figure that out.
And it's going to only get scarier
and better as time goes on.
So I think that's pretty,
pretty real.
And I think robotics is the one
that was another false start.
We had all of these Roombas and
segways and other, you know,
robotic ish devices,
hardware devices that we're going
to change the world and didn't. Um,
and now I have uh,
two startups that are using
robotics in a way that um,
our as truly disruptive.
The cafe x one is a robotic coffee machine
that maybe you'll see here in Google
one day. Um, I wouldn't be
surprised if you saw it here. Um,
and uh,
it's to coca cola machines wide.
It's got the arm and it makes your coffee
and it makes it perfectly and you can
order it on your phone.
It knows the distance you are from the
machine so it makes your coffee and under
60 seconds it gets it perfect every time
it remembers your last instructions.
I want this type of milk. I want this type
of being, I want this type of caffeine.
I want this temperature. Like you can
really dial it in. You pick it, you go,
it enhance it to you. It
takes under 45 seconds. Uh,
and so the idea of waiting
had intelligentsia,
if we're sia for how long to get a coffee,
that's about 20 minutes.
They have the same intelligency or beans
in their machine now and you'll be able
to every airport,
every two gates,
there'll be a cafe x machine and it
will cost one third less to get a cup of
coffee and it will take
19 or nine minutes left.
Everybody's been in that position where
there's like a line for coffee and you
just give up.
So the idea of people making coffee for
a living and a robot should be doing
that,
right?
It doesn't make much sense unless you
want to have like the charming experience
of a Barista with suspenders
and a big mustache. Um,
that'll still exist somewhere in the
world. And then this other company,
lockable is making modular housing
and they're going to use robotics.
So you can be able to take out
your phone or iPad and be like,
I just bought this lot over here in
Culver city and I need a house that's like
this dimensions and I
want to have it delivered.
And the robot's going to make it.
So like prefab modular at
Yahoo that made housing. Yeah.
And so it may be the same price, you
know, two or three or $400 a square foot,
but it may take out six months or
12 months of time to build a or,
and then eventually it might cost last
actually two. And were my quest, you know,
10, 20, 30% less.
But the time savings will be where the
real savings is and then they might have
four of those factories. So depending
on where you're living in the country,
you know, it could be conceivable
that you order out, uh,
a nanny unit or an in law unit.
I think they called them in the back of
your place in Culver City and you know,
it's outside your house in two days,
two days are the addition,
you laser cut the new door,
boom.
And then like literally at like the
crane drops it in your backyard.
So housing and coffee, you know, or like
two areas where robotics specialized,
they're going to do really well.
So I really believe in
looking at areas where we
had false starts. Because if
you think about, you know,
going back to youtube as an example,
there were hundreds of startups.
I tried to do video on the Internet,
but the reward for putting a video on
the Internet back then was you would,
if it went viral,
you got a $5,000 bill and then you
do the video got turned off. I mean,
some people in the room might
be too young to experiences,
but it was often that you would go to a
website that went viral and it would say
this wet,
this user has used up their bandwidth
cap and therefore you can't see the blog
post.
He couldn't afford the video accessible.
You couldn't afford to be successful.
And because of cloud computing, just,
you know, uh, Steven and Chad
had this like vision, like, wow,
it's cheap enough or we're kind of in
that range where we can kind of let people
host for free.
The idea that you could put a video
online without putting your credit card,
Ian was kind of crazy.
Now it's like four k video uploaded to
Google free forever, upload it to Itunes,
almost free forever. Like as we've
come a long way in 10 years. Uh,
so I like to look at those spaces
where people try, try, try.
I tried and that's one of the things
that investors totally by and mess up.
They always look at their personal history
and knowledge of the space and they
correlate that with, you
know, oh, it hasn't worked
before therefore work, I mean,
Google was the 11th or 12th search engine.
It was just 20 times better.
Like page rank was just that much better.
The algorithm was the why.
Now this is like a very complex algorithm
that really made the results Germanna
Chablis better. Um, and
okay,
somebody's taking another swing
at bat at an idea that, you know,
became 100 million or a billion dollar
company is worth it. And we saw that with,
you know, web van versus now
instacart and other all Google,
Amazon prime. Now Google has an,
I don't know what it's called in.
I don't know if you have the Google
delivery here to have the Google shopping
express up here or is it just in
San Francisco? Tier two. Yeah.
So like all these things that we're
using now, ubereats and Postmates,
like these were things that
were tried cosmo urban fetch,
a Web van and now just
gps, logistics, robotics.
All of this stuff has gotten so much
better that it's actually working now and
they're going to figure out
the unit economics and it's,
it's gonna change the world again to
replaying the hype cycle for new appetite
and new timing. Yup. New
Position. Look at gaming.
Like we had this whole thing
on web gaming. We're casual.
Gaming was going to be a big deal.
And then all of a sudden Facebook
came out and social gaming was a big
revolution.
That apps were a big revolution.
So you keep having these games,
you know,
waves coming one after the other.
And I think we'll have that for ar.
I think there'll be an ar gaming wave
that'll be just crazy when you can put
glasses on. I'm like, we're
all playing like paint balls,
Zombie paintball around the
office for an hour. Exactly.
It says some people with glasses on
or like watching the zombies attack,
like it's going to be a lot of fun.
So I think there's going to be something.
I think the ar stuff is the, is
really interesting. That's super,
super interesting. Can we open it to
questions? Anyone have any questions for,
for Jason? We have a microphone that
they're going to throw the box at you.
There. It is sort of,
um, so you mentioned that, uh,
you started off in journalism and then
broken to investing and you were doing it
long distance even from
just looking valley. How did
you break into the kind of,
uh,
bro Mba circles?
Because I guess investing must be a
pretty social activity. Yeah. Again,
the sequoia had this idea that they're
entrepreneurs where they invested in the,
had invested in our company,
Mahalo, which is now inside.com. Um,
they thought that it would be really cool
for founders to scout out investments
for them. And that's actually how
I did my first 15 or so investment.
So I was kind of pushed
into it by sequoia. Um,
because they had this idea to do scouts,
then they kind of created a monster
and I started doing it on my own. Um,
but now since that time I used to host
something called open Angel Forum,
which was just,
I would have a conference room at a law
firm or at somebody's house and invite
10 angel investors to see companies.
And actually thumbtack and Uber
both came to open Angel Forum,
which was Angel List, but in person. Uh,
and so now angel list exists
in these syndicates exist.
The best way to break in is to just
join as many syndicates that you can.
Funders, club, Angel List SeedInvest
and just watch the deal flow go by.
And then you could do one
of two scenarios. One,
you could play fantasy sports where
you read the deal memos and you'll say,
I think this is going to
work for these reasons.
I don't think it's going
to work for these reasons.
And my conviction level is
between one and 10. It's a seven.
And so I'm gonna pretend I put in $5,000
and I'm going to remind myself every
six months on this Google sheet to
check it on the company's valuation.
See if they raise more money and
to see if I'm good at picking.
And you could do it in a moneyball
fantasy sports kind of way,
which is what I tell young
people in colleges. You,
you're just like creating
a virtual portfolio. Um,
but now if you have a little bit of money,
I think doing this micro investing
and putting real money on the table,
we'll make your senses go
a little bit. Uh, you know,
just like playing poker for money changes
it when you're playing for, you know,
um, you know, pennies or f for fake money.
So I like the idea of going to a casino
and playing poker for a $1 $2 while
you're learning,
even though you're going to burn
through a couple of hundred bucks,
you're going to play these tournaments
and you'll feel the sting of losing your
40 bucks. You need to have that pain. So
I liked that pain for you specifically.
You look like you need to feel that pain.
So I would say just go on Angeles.
Join all this indicates,
go on seed investor and all the
syndicates and trust your gut.
Make 10 bets of $1,000 each and see
how you wind up. Now here's the secret.
You know, you're building networks
is not as hard as people think.
If you do those 10 investments,
you put $1,000 in each act as
if you put 10 or $100,000 in,
which is to say email the email
the founder, introduce yourself,
follow them on Twitter,
favorite and retweet what they do.
Look at their job board and check
in with them every 60 days and say,
how's it going?
Is there any way it can help?
And then find all your co investors in
the company by looking at crunchbase or
mattermark or any of the
publicly available places,
but that been a Google sheet and then
email the hundred of them with a mail
merge and say,
Hey,
I noticed were co-investors
in Acme company together?
Was wondering if you had any interest
in companies you're looking at?
I'm looking, I'm breaking into
angel investing. Um, and uh,
I'm investing in this company next.
So I started doing that in the early
days I was telling people like, Hey,
have you seen anything interesting?
And little,
I would do a mail merge like that
where I would email 50 people and say,
have you met any interest in companies?
Like one sentence.
And I would say half of the time people
would respond and then some people
respond three or four times.
Yeah.
Meeting with this company
I met with that company.
People are more than happy to share,
share deal flow because in
the early stages you need
probably 30 40 50 investors
before the company gets
ready for a series a.
So if you're one of the first 10 that
means there's another 40 spots left to
fill. If you're investor 50
they might only be, you know,
a couple of investments left.
So that's how you build that network is
you just email your co investor and say,
we're co investors in this. That makes
you, you know, like a family members.
You're now on a first name basis because
you're both invested in Uber together
or this company together. And what,
what other deals are you looking at?
People really don't understand how easy
it is to build a network in today's
environment with all this
information online, it's super easy.
Does that mostly work when you get a hit?
It's not really like your family? No. No,
because it's sort of like,
it's sort of like poker.
You ever get invited to a poker game
and you're a bad player and you're like,
why are they inviting me? It's like, oh,
we need some map layers that they want
your money, they want your money. No,
but also you need to fill a table,
right? So we need to fill a table.
Like we have a, we have a company
cafe acts that's just starting.
We need to raise $1 million.
We have 400,000 in,
we don't care what that next $600,000 is.
When it's that first round.
We needed to get that $600,000 so they
can prove out in 18 months that this is a
possibility that they
can build the machine,
that they can get to $1,000 a
day and profits, whatever it is.
And so again, most people overthink
it and the whole industry is cracked,
wide open because of Angel
List and seed invest.
And the reason I wrote the book was
really to try to inspire people to get
involved in it and not overthink it.
Investing and losing 1% of your net worth.
If you learn a ton.
It's going to be well worth it in my mind.
A quick followup.
If you try to tie on overthinking,
do you try to time it in terms of,
well, this thing, uh, there's been
not enough false starts quite yet,
or there's this paradigm shift and I
really should be looking in this direction
or, yeah, don't overthink it is what I,
I think because to the Twitter
example, I didn't, you know, I, I,
I understood it could become
a huge cacophony of idiots
yet I miss the obvious.
If it does, who cares if
it's a, if they're idiots
or geniuses, whatever it is,
it's a big thing and big things in
the world generate tons of wealth.
And this thing also in addition to being
a place for idiots to spew hate is a
place where revolutions can start.
Right?
So you're saying that if
you don't personally like
something that shouldn't be a
barrier toward,
I think you have to stick,
let go of your ego and what you think of
the idea and what you think of the, uh,
possibility that it could work.
Now,
if you're offended by the existence
of something that I don't think you
shouldn't fast, you're not enthusiastic.
But I, I'll give another example.
I didn't have a chance
to invest in Airbnb,
but I thought when I heard the airbnb
idea, I literally said to people,
they were like, yeah, you let, you can
rent your couch. It's like couch surfing,
so you let somebody sleep on your couch.
And I'm like, like a serial killer.
So like I led a serial killer
sleep on my couch. Or like,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
They're all like, it's a community.
And I'm like, I've serial killers.
And they're like,
no,
it's not like you could or you could
stay on someone's couch for like 50 bucks
or 30 bucks if you go to, you know,
if you couldn't afford to go to Paris,
you could stay in Paris for 30 bucks.
That's like on a serial killers couch.
Like how many people here
have stayed in an airbnb?
Raise your hand if you stayed
in an airbnb. It's everybody.
How many people have hosted
somebody as an airbnb host?
Raise your hand if you've ever done
an IRB house. One person. Okay,
how do you do?
I could net,
I could never have somebody in my
house who I don't know and do this.
Like I'm just not brave enough to do
that. And sure enough, I was like,
like how do you stop a meth head from
renting a place and just carrying it to
the ground and ripping it apart and
having a meth party. Like sure enough,
like year two of Airbnb,
it was like there's a meth party at this
woman's house and they took all their
photos and they made their own collages
and put like kill everybody on the walls.
And it was like the most horrific
horror movie ever. And I was like, Yep,
just like a hotel room. I was
like, oh, I see. I overthought it.
Like everywhere there is a,
there's 20 meth parties going on
right now in hotels in Los Angeles.
We not aware of them,
but this is what people do in hotels.
There's not parties going on I guess.
So like it's of course it's going to
happen in Airbnb and there's whatever.
So you have to be able to like again,
right?
The long list of why it's not going to
work is that there's going to be a math
party or somebody in to
tragically, uh, you know,
a ride sharing service is going to flip
a car and people are going to die. Like,
or an airplane's going to die. You know,
people are going to die in an airplane.
I just couldn't get through it in my mind.
So I think sometimes taking yourself and
your understanding of the issue in the
market out of it,
and just looking at the founder,
are they passionate and are
they making a great product?
If they're able to make a great product
and they're passionate and they're smart,
well, if the product doesn't
get that uptake from users,
they're probably gonna pivot a bit
and figure out another product.
Whereas a team of idiots who have such a
great story about how big the market is,
but they can't build a really great
product, they're not going to succeed.
They're just not going to succeed. Cool.
Thanks. I think you have a question here.
In the other hand I'll do shorter answers.
What about the people raising
money with virtual currency?
Now it's a great question.
Um,
I have looked at the companies and I
would say the first wave of ISOS are
extremely scary.
It reminds me of the.com bubble.
So I'd be very careful.
People who have crazy
ideas have not built them.
Raising 30 million or $100 million
is a recipe for disaster. Um,
in the height of the Dotcom boom,
we had people raising money or taking
companies public based on the idea that
they would raise $100 million and then
figure out what to do with it. Right.
There was a company called Cmgi,
I remember that was like an incubator
and all these companies were going public
with the idea that they
would create companies.
She had people who are creating
ICO for products that don't exist,
that are crazy ideas. We'll
one of them work. Sure, we'll
99 of them fell probably.
And so I,
and then where's this money coming from?
And this money is dark money from,
I think the crypto boom.
So people have a ton of a theory and
we're a ton of bitcoin. Like, okay,
I will diversify it.
So I'll buy all these ICRS.
It feels like the ultimate Ponzi
scheme to me. It's real technology.
It could have a real impact.
But this early cohort,
I would not be surprised if almost all
of them went to zero and all of that
money got burned and there were massive
lawsuits around it and that there was
massive fraud occurring. Right now.
I believe Bitcoin is probably, uh,
one of the most massively manipulated
currencies in the world where most
manipulated things in the world.
What's to stop somebody from creating
100,000 wallets were 10 of us from
creating a hundred thousand wallets each
and moving a bunch of bitcoins around,
uh,
and making it look like there's all this
volume and then making the sh the share
price go up.
Like there's a lot of ability to
manipulate anonymous currencies and um,
the sec is not very,
uh,
we talked a little bit earlier about
non accredited versus unaccredited.
Like the SEC. They do not have a, um,
a, uh, what's the right way to say it?
They're not looking for
creative solutions, uh,
to be put into the market with people's
money at risk. They're risk averse,
they're whole reason to exist is to
protect people from losing their money and
being tracked.
These things seem like people could get
tracked and can lose their money and
then a lot of people are like,
it's not an offering it,
it's not like a stock offering. And
then the people buying it are buying it.
When you asked them
why are they buying it,
they're saying because it's going
to go up in value. But if they're,
if the people buying it believe it's a
security and you are pretending it's not
while you're cashing in
tens of millions of dollars,
this is I think a disingenuous. So some
people who are taking in the money in,
I know a are doing things like I'm paying
taxes on it saying it's future revenue
form software because this
our API calls or whatever.
So they're actually going
to pay their taxes on it,
pay as if its profits against software
revenue. So I think that's smart. Um,
I do think that the fund,
having a venture fund
where the LP interests,
the limited partners are in coins and
are on a ledger is inevitable and that
people will then be able
to trade their interest.
So if you were in the sequoia fund with
Google at the IPO or right before the
IPO and you want it to sell your shares
to another person or you're a benchmark
right now in the Uber situation where
Uber and benchmark or fighting, if Uber,
if benchmark shares were freely tradable
and the lps could trade them well they
might liquidate right now or they might
be wanting to buy from another party.
Right?
And so you'd have this more fluidity.
So I do think that that
will come very quickly,
like two or three years and
other countries are going
to lead it because we are
very conservative when it comes to this.
So I think Scandinavian
countries and Asian company,
Asian countries and the companies
are going to be very fluid with it.
But I'm monitoring it because you know,
if you are a fund,
if you have funds like I have
had or have, you know, it's a,
it's an interesting concept. I'm, I'm
certainly a believer in the technology,
but I also saw a lot of companies I think
in that group that I just thought they
could not clear market
with the venture community.
Now it doesn't mean the venture community
is perfect or the angel community
perfect,
but they tend to know what they're
doing and that machine is a well oiled
machine that knows how to take risk.
So if there,
if the well oiled machine of Silicon
Valley and venture money and angel money
passed on investing in these companies
and then they were able to raise from
dark pools of capital of
unsophisticated people,
I don't know. I don't know if
there's that much wisdom in crowds.
I'm very worried about it. I think we
have time for a couple more questions.
Do you have a question? Yeah.
Uh, I actually had a couple,
I'm the first one was, um,
on average,
how many of your initial
investments significantly
change product direction? Um,
at like prototyping stage or
initial customer base. Um,
and then another question would be on,
um,
how many investments have you made or
how do you usually see where you're
investing in someone who's a,
also like for example,
like working at Google but has legal,
uh,
acceptance to work on a product on the
side or maybe any of the big five and
that have, uh, have,
have done very well those companies
and they let her on quit of course. Um,
and then maybe just how you see in terms
of a silica, US Southern California,
excluding silicone valley, where do you
see southern California against, uh,
the other, uh, cities
in the u s yeah, so we,
we talked before technology and talent
can come from anywhere. So I don't think,
um,
and I think southern California is so
close to silicon valley and the people in
Silicon Valley,
especially investors and people who
live there are kind of tired of silicon
valley. It's, it's pretty horrible to
live there right now because of cost,
because of homelessness, because of
crime. It's much better to live here, uh,
to be honest. Like it's a much better
lifestyle, like five times better.
So I think you have a lot of them
who are moving down here. Uh,
and a lot of people who are willing to
move down here because it's literally
like, it's like a borrow, right?
It's a one hour flight. Um,
to your question about people
doing their side hustle,
I think most investors like to see a
clean break because they want to know that
you're all in.
So I generally don't invest when people
are doing those kind of side hustles. Uh,
even if they have permission, we
want to get a clean break. No,
you're full time on it and then make the
investment but willing to meet and see
the prototype.
But I've been in a lot of cases where
people have those side hustles and they've
got permission from their manager and
then the big five company is like, yeah,
we're going to pull you back in cause
we kind of liked your side hustle and
let's get that back in the company.
So because those big five
are so competitive with
startups now and aware of the
startup ecosystem,
um,
I think a clean break is the wisest way
to go if you want to raise from serious
people. Um, and most companies
pivot here and there.
Um,
the term pivot used to mean taking
what you've learned and changing your
direction slightly.
One foot staying where it is
and then you're moving around.
The word pivot somehow meant dropping
the existing idea and coming up with a
completely different idea. That's
not the term pivot as we all use it,
but people are like,
we're pivoting and pivoting now in
silicon valley means this fouled.
Now we're doing this. That's not
pivoting. Pivoting is we were going to go,
you know,
and do video for the enterprise.
But then we found this new
class of prosumers so we're
kind of going to make it
pro-sumer where it's free for most
people and paid for the elite people.
But it's not going to be an enterprise
video solution anymore. Cause we, we,
we realized the enterprise, you
know, they'd like to roll their own.
That would be a pivot.
You're staying in the same vertical,
you're shifting the
customer base a little bit,
but the product and everything
is in the same zone.
So that happens in almost every
company where you learn as you go.
It's very few get it right.
And in fact if you look at Uber like is
going into ride sharing and Uber Pool a
pivot. No, but maybe in
the classic term it was,
we started with black cars,
Lincoln town cars, expensive cars.
We pivoted to ride sharing like we
added it, you know, we, we folk,
we moved our focus over a bit to it.
Um,
so I think it depends on which
definition of pivot you're going with.
Um, but you know, there, there are
people like Stewart Butterfield who did,
who did flicker after doing a failed video
game and did slack after doing a fail
video game. I mean, basically if he had,
if he does a v another video game company,
I'm investing, it's just for the
pivot, really good video game.
The video game will never be released
and $1 billion company will come out the
other side.
That has something to do with the team
that's building the failed video game.
Like the second he succeeds at a
video game, I'm going to be worried.
All right. Is the felon back still
here? It doesn't look like he is. Um,
I think that's all the time we had
for questions. Thank you so much. Uh,
if anybody wants me to sign their book,
I'm willing to do that as well. All right.
Thank you very much.